with trey links
thanks trey i know you had a russian
side moments ago what is happening there
tell us
laura gunfire is erupting across the
city of kiev at this moment off in the
distance we heard gunfire and explosions
around the central part of this capital
city in ukraine but just a few moments
ago gunfire started coming from all
different directions so we had to move
inside very quickly there were a number
of tracer rounds you could also see in
the distance indicating this is really
widespread in the city it's not just one
location where there are ukrainian
troops battling russian forces ukrainian
president vladimir zelinsky warned of
this scenario basically saying tonight
would be the night that decides the fate
of ukraine
clearly the russians are facing some
fierce resistance in the streets of kiev
and tonight again the gunfire continues
inside the city limits and we know
outside of the city there are reports of
more russian troops trying to make their
way to the ukrainian capital russia
attacking ukraine from multiple
directions and attacking the city from
multiple directions it's not just kiev
tonight where there is renewed violence
taking place also kharkiv the second
largest ukrainian city taking a lot of
fire according to reports we are going
to limit what we say about the ukrainian
side and the russian side tonight in
terms of statements about a different
accusations that have been made by both
sides uh reports of planes being shut
down and the like uh we want to hold off
on this information because there's a
lot of things flying around tonight uh
what we can report is what we can see
and what we know based on who we have
talked to and that is that there are
russian troops inside the ukrainian
capital of kiev at this moment it is a
worst case scenario for the ukrainian
forces but the
russian troops are faced with some
difficult days ahead according to the
people that we have talked to everyone
from civilians to army troops to members
of parliament say they will fight tooth
and nail to protect this city and they
will not allow the russians to occupy it
laura trey trey president zielinski um
made it quite clear
in his last appearance um on video
that it may be the last time he speaks
to his people uh because he believes
he's target number one has he said his
family is target number two
we're showing the video now
uh he's on the move we don't know where
he is obviously he's he wants to keep
safe but also he's not leaving that
country as some
uh so-called leaders have abandoned
theirs as we saw in afghanistan
any sense of of his ability to rally the
people at this hour
he is trying his hardest to rally the
people speaking directly to his
population saying that they must resist
the russians
the difficult part here is that russia
comes to this battle with air power and
ground power that the ukrainians
early on will be able to push back and
we have seen that in the early hours of
this fight
but it is not sustainable and it's part
of the reason that you saw ukrainian
president zielinski
appealing to the international community
and and pleading with them to send
weapons to this country and while today
or yesterday
you had the nato secretary general jen
stoltenberg
say there will be air defense systems
delivered to ukraine the big question is
how are they going to deliver those
systems
there is no air travel into this country
right now martial law is declared
because fighting is erupting in the
streets of the capital and it's it's too
late really i mean this battle will
likely continue they're not giving up
you can hear it out in the streets
tonight
but the question is how will they get
more supplies here yeah man they blocked
the first thing you do is take the
airports and they've secured the airport
so trey thank you for staying with us
please stay safe you've done
unbelievable work for us there tonight
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else